je pense que l'abstention s'explique par
la structuration du pays aujourd'hui on
est dans un régime politique
présidentielle chacun sait depuis le
général de gaulle donc il se trouve que
tous les sept ans n'a guère tous les
cinq ans aujourd'hui il ya une sorte de
grande coupe du monde comme ça en france
qui s'appelle les présidentielles pour
lesquels tout le monde s'excite comme
nous en ce moment un an six mois avant
il ya des qualifications des badges
poule et ensuite une fois que cette
élection a eu lieu les français s'en
désintéressent même aux législatives qui
ont lieu depuis le quinquennat ce qui
est une grave erreur à mon avis juste
après l'élection présidentielle les
français sont déjà beaucoup moins
nombreux à voter qu'ils sont allés au
président c'est donc cette élection
parce qu'on en sait sont peut-être un
peuple un monarchiste dans l'âme
concentre tout le tous les espoirs et le
reste les intéresse pas oui bah c'est
exactement ça je crois qu'il ya une
infantilisation de fête de la démocratie
par la vème république est encore
accentuée par le quinquennat en disant
l'élection majeure c'est la
présidentielle et on y va un peu pour
jouer c'est un peu comme un pari on va
avoir son son cheval et puis on va
parier ou son baril de lessive on va
dire voilà on y va mais quand on voit
effectivement sur les élections
intermédiaires c'est une catastrophe les
records d'abstention c'est les
municipales c'est les régionales c'est
pourtant là que se font la gestion de la
commune la gestion de la vie citoyenne
de la vie en commun on voit bien que les
français se désintéressent finalement
d'être citoyen or le droit de vote c'est
important si on n'utilise pas pourquoi
l'avoir et on a l'impression que c'est
pas un droit de vote c'est un droit de
jouer on va jouer à l'élection
présidentielle on va jouer à la
démocratie et derrière on a cinq ans
comme on vient de vivre avec ce
quinquennat macron ou bien finalement le
parlement est inexistant parce qu'on a
une assemblée de députés godillots
playmobil comme on les appelait qui ne
servent même pas à débattre qui sont là
pour être une caisse enregistreuse d'une
chambre d'enregistrement des décisions
par décret de l'exécutif et accentue
encore la crise du commis de là on a
vraiment vu la caricature de la
cinquième